Prince Harry and his fiancee Megan
Merkel are opening up about their
courtship and romance
Harry's engagement with the American
actress is dominating newspapers this
morning one of the headlines perhaps
says it best she's the one the couples
spoke yesterday with our partners at the
BBC in their first joint television
interview Charlie d'Agata is at
Kensington Palace in London Charlie good
morning good morning he may be a prince
and she may be a famous TV star but the
proposal took place over chicken dinner
here at home although in this case home
is Kensington Palace once Prince Harry
got down on bended knee Megan didn't
think twice that chemistry is no Act
says BBC correspondent Michelle Hussein
who conducted the interview what you see
in the film of the two of them together
and the way they interacted with each
other was absolutely how they were off
camera as well I was really struck by
the obvious bond between the two of them
Harry is already tried to distance the
couple from a media he is condemned as
operating with racial undertones in some
of the early coverage of Megan who
describes herself as biracial of course
it's disheartening you know it's it's a
shame that that is the climate in this
world to focus that much on that or that
that would be discriminatory in that
sense but I think you know at the end of
the day I'm really just proud of Who I
am and where I come from and we have
never put any focus on that we've just
focused on who we are as a couple and
Harry said he really had to make sure
she knew where she was going
you know I still have to have some
pretty you know frank conversations with
her to say that you know what you're
letting yourself in for is it is it's a
big it's a big deal
whatever
we have to tackle together or
individually will always be us together
as a team a team that will always
include living with the legacy of
Princess Diana the little diamonds
either side are from my mother's juried
collection to make sure that she's with
us on this on this crazy journey
together and it's beautiful and he
designed it it's incredible yeah yeah
make sure it stays on my finger this
morning Kate reacted to news of the
engagement saying William and I are
thrilled it's such exciting news it's a
really happy time for any couple and us
gal I love everything about them Charlie
d'Agata thank you thank you so much